let's cover what china just said i mean
which is a pretty wild announcement here
about china's advancement in
their military china carries out first
successful tests of underwater
explosives that could destroy us ports
after launching satellite crushing
weapon and hypersonic missile
daily mail story china has carried out
his first demolition of port using
underwater explosive tactic that states
state media said could be used against
the u.s in an event of war beijing's
military carried out test on saturday
using underwater charges to destroy
dummy wharf at an undisclosed location
somewhere in china the technology is
designed to cut off enemy supply lines
in the event of a conflict and sneak
attacks under using underwater charges
will make large vessels like u.s
aircraft carriers vulnerable it is just
the latest in a string of chinese
military tests including the launch of a
satellite last week that the u.s warns
could attack other spacecraft uh and two
tests of an orbital weapon that analysts
think is a hypersonic nuke
this sounds like a movie but this is not
a movie this is a real story china has
the ability to kill us all ten times
right i mean they're going to get us
like 16 different ways i hope we have
smart people in our military too i hope
maybe we just don't have to broadcast
and publicize everything that we're
capable of doing i still think
that the amount of money that we spend
on defense and and how advanced we are
and i don't know i mean these stories
are kind of scary and it does show that
china
is so intent on presenting to the world
that they're a military power and maybe
this is more of a soft warning towards
taiwan in some of the other areas japan
no doubt they said u.s specifically yeah
they're they're they're they're
preparing long-term here's one thing you
got to give credit to them for
they have a common enemy sure it's u.s
okay it's everybody that is against them
is their common enemy in u.s we don't
have a common enemy the enemy in us the
enemy of the republican is a damn the
enemy of the dem is a republican this is
like the most united state nation in the
world today when it comes down to their
politics and that's what makes us
vulnerable that's exactly it so if we
were united on who the enemy is it'd be
a different story but because you are
not united on who the enemy is a country
like china keeps advancing well china's
already playing a damn good game of
economic warfare if you think about this
supply chain disruption 24
of the of the components in your average
u.s vehicle are being made in china
25 24. right a lot of them are stuck on
barges right now on the ship they're not
even getting here yeah and then you've
got this potential
strike coming up in in
i mean payback is a excuse my
french but joe biden's 90 day sprint
we're going to keep those long beach and
long los angeles workers they're they're
going to work three three shifts a day
24 7 get get us through the holidays
make sure they unload all these
containers oh and by the way
their their contract comes up for
renegotiation and expires on june 30th
every single year since 1990 when
they've renegotiated their contract
they've shut the port down
well they got the ultimate leverage by
doing it do you know what they want this
time instead of just more money and
benefits and by the way the highest paid
union unionized workers in the country
we're talking about here
highest the teamsters no no this is the
long shore okay yeah so by the way you
can get them i think on tuesday okay
because this will still be a story i
think he's running behind
it's gonna be a story it's gonna be a
bigger and bigger story because what
what the workers want to do and this is
this is gonna bristle you the workers
don't just want higher pay and benefits
they want to stop the port operators
from automating
well yeah because that takes away jobs
right and exactly they want that written
into their contract if you can win
and like they can't unload the
containers as it is they need to
automate as quickly as possible we need
to you know get the supply chain
disruption undisrupted
and the union wants to take automation
and put it in writing that they cannot
automate yeah this is this is this is
becoming a bigger story than it was just
a few months back so
los angeles long beach ports to fine
shipping companies over backlog this is
a hill story officials for the ports of
los angeles long beach on monday said
that they will begin finding shipping
companies whose cargo containers stay in
marine terminals for too long as they
work to reduce congestion in their ports
port of long beach executive director
said with the escalating backlog backlog
of ships off the coast we must take
immediate action to prompt a rapid
removal of containers from our marine
terminals adding that the ports are
running out of space the fees collected
from idling containers will be invested
into programs meant to enhance
efficiency on ocean carriers will be
charged a hundred dollar per container
with the fines increasing in hundred
dollar increments per day per container
increasing per day per container i'm
backing that container up i'm backing
the whole thing up but i'm going to
houston or i'm going to miami
if they start to do things like this the
only thing with this though from what i
was reading is it's it's not like when
they're on there it's more when they get
off because okay you unload the ship but
if it's just staying at the at the uh
there's no truckers yeah at the port
then you're screwed 100 trucking
companies went out of business a hundred
trucking companies went out of business
and even when you unload the containers
who's going to pick them up
i mean railroads have come out and said
in the last few days the railroads have
come out and said
our volumes are down because we don't
have truckers to pick up the containers
from the rail heads and take them around
the country 80 000 trucker shortage the
average trucker is 55 years old making
18 bucks an hour only seven percent are
women 93 are men
drug and alcohol issue that they've had
meaning they had an experience with it
and they got you know maybe a
misdemeanor or something 91 000 at least
have one violation 72 000 currently
suspended 54 000 have not started
reinstatement process
we are down 80 000 trucker shortage and
this is taking place this is a scary
thought when you're thinking about
what's going on right now so this is
when a desantis is sitting there saying
hey come on down here we'll be able to
work for you come on down here we'll be
able to get this thing going for you you
don't have to sit there and worry about
that part so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]